youtube you're about to watch a fire q a
session i did on clubhouse
excuse me i don't know if you've seen
the app but pretty popular exploding
uh really interesting audio platform and
i'm hosting these q a's uh quite often
on the platform so
a if you're in the app it's garyvee like
everywhere else
come and follow me up and be sit back
enjoy this
and uh see please leave a comment and
let me know what you think of it
everybody i'm uh i'm recording this
with the potential to use it as a clip
on instagram to help other people
so just wanted to keep that in mind i
wanted to make that uh
aware to everybody and let's get into it
who's got a question
raise your hands mate and just bring in
people william how are you
that is basically the same mindset i
roll with i'm well what can i help you
with any questions
that little red recording sign plus the
recording
and then my question is i'm trying to
build like a super sticky community
in plug-offs upon is that i don't have
any content that i can use
to like evergreen things or to repurpose
i have to just non-stop
keep uh talking and it's really starting
to get exhausting i'm just wondering if
you have any tips on how i might be able
to
be a little bit more efficient but also
continue to build a really really strong
community
because i mean your your family base is
one of the most
loyal and lovable of loving of you on
earth
so you know it's funny i look at
clubhouse a lot like i
look at um twitter from 2007 to 11
and that's really where it started for
me
i i basically replied to every single
comment
that i got for four years and it was
an incredible amount of work but to your
point william like
if you're going to build something
meaningful you got to put in the work
i've gone on this four or five year
um maybe even six now yeah actually six
six year
health journey and it's like every day
you know just like eating as well
as i can working out being thoughtful
soft tissue stretching
muscle gain you know i think i think
you may want to pace yourself in here a
little bit
that might be one thing to think about
you know going 11 hours of talking or
six hours of talking or nine hours of
talking
every day is can get quite exhausting
plus the other thing to think about is
giving yourself permission
to really just relax on a day or two
in case it's too much is something else
to think about
so you can go hard but it's about
figuring out
um you know the ability to
give yourself a moment because i think
scaling the unscalable william
is the way you actually build something
meaningful
by actually scaling the unscalable
meaning
the hand-to-hand combat the constant
talking the non-evergreen the high touch
is the game
right because because because what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
win on depth
right because that's how you actually
build something that's
that's sticky you know with ak
viral videos or a content play it's
actually access and actually
feeling connected like i genuinely feel
connected
to so many people within my community um
it's really what ends up happening i
think the bigger i think you're on it
i just think you need to figure out your
pace because we all have different
energies of how many hours we can put
into it
right it's like um hosting a room every
single day so we have like one of the
stickiest spaces for real estate agents
and brokers in clubhouse right now
and we're getting approached by
different people for like podcasts
and like consulting and things like this
and we're also
really trying to build up a coalition of
creators across the different spaces as
well
because as um clubhouse basically
prepares for monetization in two weeks
we want to make sure we have
as strong of a grouping as possible and
that everyone in clubhouse and creators
ideally we can stay allies
so we can have a lot of
cross-pollination of audiences i think
i think that's great and all but i think
if you listen
back to the recording of this of this my
my big recommendation is to understand
the second that you go for monetization
is the second that you change your
relationship
about right clubhouse is going to
monetize but for me my personal brand
it's never going to be about
monetization because i i get enough
income from my real estate streams
well well it's clubhouse is not going to
monetize without you sharing in that
monetization
that's a really good point and they're
like um
let's let's let's let's stay on that for
a second and i'll definitely answer this
like
like it's a ve you know
having al really when you talked about
allies and other community members what
you were really talking about
was creating scale for monetization
if you really think about it which is
okay what i think i've done
differently than a lot of people over
the last 2007 let's call it
you know 14 13 15 years
is i've never
tried to monetize directly on
the pers like i wrote books so a
publisher paid me i
spoke so a conference paid me right
even even my wine thing it's like look
if you buy wine cool i'd like your
business but
the core of what i do has been
around brand building and community not
about the monetization i think a lot of
people are about to make massive
missteps
in monetization with clubhouse because
they're going to
think transactional and short term and
they're going to think it's long term
like whoa i've been [ __ ] going hard
on here for six months and that [ __ ]
makes me laugh
because because that's just not a long
time
right it's a point yeah so just keep
that in mind i mean the longer you can
provide
this before don't forget the second
you're going to come to the ui of this
and there's monetized rooms and there's
not
a lot of people are going to pick the
non-monetized rooms because the
information is going to be just as good
to be really hard for somebody to sell
marketing in social media rooms
if i'm in here putting out [ __ ] for free
right absolutely absolutely or it's not
going to be hard
but but it's going to be limiting in
their upside
right absolutely so with with me and and
the collaborators i i've connected with
we have a pretty good sizeable platform
so as you come to class in the future
are there any initiatives that you want
to accomplish in clubhouse that we can
assist with
no but i i really genuinely appreciate
that i'm gonna keep moving because i got
meetings soon so i want to get this many
in so i appreciate you bro
monica
is amazing because um are in my year in
the podcast
for like the last two weeks ongoing but
i've got quite a tactical question for
you
um so i'm into marketing social media
that's what i
help entrepreneurs with uh and i've had
quite a big plans for this year in terms
of scaling up and kind of getting myself
out there be seen more and things like
that obviously
things happen out of control lock down
home schooling and just
things have to she had to keep a little
bit
i'm not averse to hard work long nights
if i have to and things like that
but i do want to make the most of what i
have so
which platforms social media platforms
and what
tactics would you say
at the best now or beginning of 2021
that should be my let's say top two
priorities monica for
for transactions or for brand building
building and getting myself out there
basically getting more reach well i
think you're on it right now clubhouse
is a land grab right now right
like you know obviously back to your
point with kids and
balancing everything unfortunately for
most people clubhouse is a challenging
platform because it requires you putting
in the work
you know for example for me i'm so busy
running my companies right now
i'm not putting in the hours into
clubhouse that i would like to
because the land grab of attention is
extraordinary
it's an incredible time if you really
know what you're doing
to start rooms be get part of rooms and
really showcase your knowledge um and
build incredible audience
i think clubhouse linkedin and tick tock
are the three platforms that have
organic reach that are extraordinary
compared to the amount of time
or content you put out those are the
three brand building platforms that i
think are most
significantly interesting because of
supply and demand of attention
there's more attention on all three
platforms than the supply of content
which is why you're getting more organic
reach
yeah with club cars i've only been here
a week and i have to say i've been
amazed i've set up a
room twice and i just want to kind of
carry on doing it because i see how
quickly it can
kind of grow
nobody can do everything there's two
games to play when you think about
social media
or about personal brand building or
about marketing it's
where is there more attention than their
supply of content
and then number two being self-aware
i can tell you and i'm very confident
about this that tick tock
clubhouse and linkedin are three places
worth your time
because when you put your time on
youtube twitter instagram facebook you
don't get as much
in organic reach as you do on those
other platforms
but if you're not capable of being good
on tick tock linkedin and clubhouse
then you're not going to succeed either
if you're more great at visual pictures
and infographics then maybe pinterest
and instagram
are gonna over index for you so it's a
game of self-awareness
and strategy you've got to deploy both
s's in this scenario
self-awareness do you know yourself what
will you be good at and then strategy
do you actually know where the getting
is good
is amazing because i actually i love the
video i love that's how i prefer to talk
then
than write and this clubhouse is pretty
good i like tick tock because it's a bit
i i can put my fun side to it as well
correct um
so i think i think you're right your
spot on that about the content as well
and those platforms getting
myself out there so thanks for that
you're welcome have a great day
will what's good
hey gary thanks for taking this um
question for you i have a
seven-year-old who is obsessed with
being an influencer
how do i support her and help her
without being
crazy overprotective dad it's a great
question man
so um this is a very common
scenario this has become the greatest
ambition
for many seven-year-olds i think it's
similar though
to athletes and you know and
singers and for athletes and their
parents
are more accustomed to that question
will then i want to be a youtuber
a because they know that they have to
put in the work
at a youth protective place and then
maybe when they're 18 something can
happen
versus a nine-year-old can actually pop
on tick-tock and have that happen
i think for me and
um parenting advice is always very
challenging because
like anything it's back to the prior
question it's always self-awareness it's
always
individuals of one it's tough to get
blanket but i'll tell you the thing
that's been very clear to me
as i've talked to you know hundreds of
thousands of parents through the
last two decades uh or at least a decade
for sure
on this topic i think it's about
self-esteem will i think you've got to
get her comfortable with negative
feedback
i think one of the great things of if
she's going to make a youtube video
that's private to the family and you're
going to understand your privacy i mean
as you know probably with me
my two kids are 11 and 8 and there's no
content about them out there so
everybody treats it differently every
family makes their own rules but i will
tell you
the big opportunity is getting them
accustomed to failure it's why sports
was such a good thing for kids getting
used to losing
is a really really good thing and a lot
of
society's in you know under
performance comes from insecurity which
comes with a poor relationship to losing
and i think when we started as a
parenting society 20 years ago
demonized losing and coming up with
eighth place trophies we created a lot
of vulnerabilities
and so i think you protect because
privacy and
you know like seven is a baby however on
the flip side
even if like you make the network 25
family and friends and relatives
and when she gets six likes instead of
13
it's a good lesson for her to say hey
today people didn't like your dance as
much as yesterday and that's okay
just but it's okay for you to love the
dance did you love doing the dance it
only got six likes but did you love it
getting them into a relationship where
they don't over or undervalue
outside affirmation as early as possible
is the greatest gift the parent can give
a child thoughts will
yeah no i mean i agree with you i think
it's it's such a hard thing to
jump in because obviously i know what's
out there i know
um that is not all you know
uh it's not all cupcakes and rainbows so
um where would you say starting or out
with um
i think i think it's a closed network
right it's 12 family members on tick
tock 12 family members on youtube
you know that's that's how my brain
works on it keep it closed at first
so that she can calibrate
sounds good do you think teaching her
the behind the scenes stuff the
you know setting up the mic setting up
the cameras like that's obviously
important as well
i would argue that it's potentially
important right it's really neat i think
you should try
you know because she may find tremendous
interest in that you know that wouldn't
have worked for me
if my mom did that for me i would have
been like who cares i'm here for the
action
the human interaction you know
no completely that makes sense so i
think it's a good explorer of course
well have a great day
robert hey gary
um thank you thank you so much for this
um just want to take
one second to say you have been
probably the single most important um
at person as far as business go for
helping me
get my things off the ground and i just
want to thank you for that first of all
i appreciate it for my own knowledge
robert because it's important
what what clicked what what stood out
that actually helped you
honestly i launched a fashion brand in
2008 and i loved it but then the love
for it just kind of started to go
and then one day at the gym my dad was
actually in the hospital
and i was just kind of at a crossroads
and i opened up youtube and watched the
it might have been scientific or
teachable
something that you that you had out
there and literally
right like went down a a black hole of
just
garyvee video after garyvee video over
about a 48 hour span
and um it just like it just opened my
eyes up to this world of
branding social media marketing et
cetera
and the rest is kind of the history i
literally built a quarter million dollar
um social media agency um and i know a
lot of people have
um off of your principles so again thank
you for everything
of course um my question
is uh i'm at
i'm at a place where i know i can scale
i hate the idea of the ebooks and the
downloads
and i like i want to continue to give
info for free
like i said i've used kind of like your
approach when it comes to that
um my when i doubled my business from
probably 75 000
to 150 000 the thing that changed was
that i hired i found someone that
just clicked and could i could duplicate
myself
and so i feel like that's like i don't
want to say it's a look thing but it's
just
not always like you can't go find that
person to help you scale
so like my question is the other route
would be raising prices
which i i love where i am as far as
pricing go
so my question is where what would you
recommend um
would be the best route to go to the
next level in terms of scaling
why why yeah
i have several i mean you know i
why are you happy where where you're at
price wise
um i just like being able to serve
individuals who might not necessarily
have
well how much is it i'm sorry
how much is it so right now my average
price point
is about 2 000 um for
monthly social media management
well that's not so affordable
like why not do 300 bucks
300 you said that you wanted you loved
helping people that might not else be
afforded so
at 2 000 a month that's real coin why
not 300 bucks
but then that would require a lot more
resources and people understood so let's
go a different way
why not three thousand dollars
i mean you've made a yeah you've made a
subjective arbitrary decision
that two thousand dollars a month is a
fair price
right you're making a complete
subjective call
so what you're doing is you're limiting
your upside
on scale through you know so for example
me i love managing people i love
hr headaches i love people quitting and
calling out sick i love the grind
of that robert 99 of people do not
so for me if i'm in your spot i'm going
to 1500
and i'm hiring people and i'm making
less money every year but i'm gonna
i'm gonna stack fifteen hundreds at
scale that's what i did with vaynermedia
now vaynermedia is 200 million a year
right
that's my style but your style
may not be that and that's amazing
myself is not better my style is
my style what i'm trying to help you
with and the reason i went with that
little
you know rope-a-dope was
if you're gonna if you're gonna say 300
doesn't work or 1500 doesn't work
you've just literally made a subjective
opinion that 2000 works
you can go to 3 500 and there's your
scale
that makes a ton of sense that's what
we're here for
thank you and for people that don't know
like the gary in real life versus the
gary on the stage
is just like it's almost mind-blowing
how
like humble you are in real life so
thank you for everything you do
thank you bro hey charity how are you
hi good morning thank you so much uh for
taking my question
um so my name is charity and i own a
women's boutique
and my issue is that for someone that is
naturally
very reserved um
but also loves fashion and i am working
to try to build that
no like and trust factor with my
audience
how do i balance sharing the personal
you know background story building my
story
for my brand um with my audience without
maybe sharing too much like is there a
balance to
it charity charity
i i have i have two children 11 and 8
and you don't even know what they look
like
right i'm the most public private person
on earth
right
by sharing by sharing what you want to
share and by not sharing what you don't
want to share
okay i mean people people make me laugh
they're in complete control
charity you know where people get hurt
and i don't think this is your situation
but i'm trying to help a lot of people
there's a bunch of people listening
people are full of [ __ ] they want the
likes so they're willing to wear skimpy
clothes they want the likes
so they're willing to show their cute
kid they want the likes so they're
showing their dog they want the likes so
they're showing where they live
what they're flying what they're like
you're in control
you don't want to share don't share you
want to share share
and if you want to grow share as much
good stuff around what you do want to
share and as much volume
as you can handle and as much you know
strategy as you can learn
does that make sense to you
yes it was it's something that you know
i am
of course i've not been in business but
i'm just trying to
you know put myself out there but in a
way that's comfortable for me
the end the end like if it's
if it listen i could be the best social
media strategist on earth but if i tell
you to dance on tick tock and you can't
dance
because i can't [ __ ] dance that's not
going to work
right like just because people are like
you have to build your personal brand
cool but you're going to do that on your
rules
not on somebody else's and by the way
there's a billion businesses out there
that are crushing
that the person behind it isn't out and
about it's just a very incredible
opportunity but it doesn't mean it's
required
right thank you so much for that
i appreciate it i appreciate it
it makes sense right charity like like
like there's this incredible opportunity
but it doesn't mean it's required and i
think that's where you have to figure it
out
i would tell you as somebody who sees
the incredible opportunity
figure it out in your own skin talk
about it your own way
and be you
yes like if you know some people
some people are monotone like i just
happen to be very
boisterous but i'll be honest with you
charity i'm very
misunderstood and underrated for my
business vacuum because people think i'm
a caricature
like like i would argue that my big
personality undermines my intellect
every day of my life
you know and and when you have pride and
feelings and a human
you know people dismiss you know my 25
years of building actual businesses on
like
getting lucky on social media like you
know what i mean like people are always
going gonna have judgment you gotta do
you
right okay
thank you thank you so much you're
welcome you got it charity
have a great day austin
hey gary i really appreciate this this
is like
an amazing opportunity i just wanted to
thank you real quick for for allowing me
to be on here
um you know i actually took a lot of
your words and that's what inspired me
to create my youtube channel
you know because just real quick a
little background i'm activating
military
i'm coming from a really small town in
southern west virginia so you know
statistically
i should not be you know financially
free or anything like that because
military makes crap and all that
but um that's part of my theme of my
youtube channel right is
i love talking about finances real
estate investing stock market investing
all this stuff to you know really
lay down that financial path and my
question to you
is um where i'm just i have a really
small
following and a lot of the people i've
talked to i've been fortunate to talk to
a few big youtubers and they you know
tell me you know find your theme find
what sets
you apart from other youtubers and stuff
to
you know really catch people's attention
and one of the aspects i follow from you
is you know
always focus on giving people value and
that's what i really love to do
but i don't really have you know an
audience to say hey i like this or hey
you should do that or whatever
how do you find you know the thing that
just
naturally sets you apart from other
people without trying to i don't
look like you're trying to do that you
know what i mean of course i do first of
all i think that naturally happens by
being a human being first and first and
first of all
thank you so much for your service
austin i really mean that number two
back to the question you're gonna be you
you're gonna be set apart by you to
begin with i think again there's general
advice that sometimes puts people down
the wrong path
i think what you need to do is build an
audience first
and i think it's very hard to do that on
youtube it you know first of all takes a
long time
and it takes a lot of craft and i think
you being on
clubhouse right now if i'm you i'm
starting a room right now
called like military investment advice
and just sitting in
at first it's six people that were from
the military or
grew up in the military or military like
i think you just find places that you
can naturally build audience i think you
can build a much bigger audience on
clubhouse than you can on youtube every
day of the week right now for the next
six months
i don't think i i don't want you to make
a decision that it has to be
youtube
okay you know that that's that's really
awesome honestly i have thought about
that
um the main thing is yeah like you said
like
if i'm just starting a room and i'm
sitting there talking to myself like i
didn't know how to you know really just
the the best way the best way to start
talking
is to be a great listener when nobody
knew who i was on twitter all i did was
reply to people on twitter about wine
because that's what i knew
what you can do is first
become a contributor to a lot of rooms
that talk about finance and investing
speak towards that military angle and
start amassing i mean you've already got
you know you know 76 followers in here
nobody knew who the [ __ ] you were you
probably said some [ __ ]
that mattered in some room and people
started following you i think you need
to become a contributor before you
become a host
go to dinner parties before you throw
one if you moved to a new town
and everything was about the dinner
party scene
you couldn't just throw a dinner party
when you first moved in nobody would
show up nobody knows who you are you
just moved in
what you want to do is talk to somebody
at the market and then they invite you
to
their dinner party right then you go to
that dinner party and you do a
nice job conversating 18 months later
you're throwing a dinner party
got it that's that's awesome man yeah
i'll definitely do that thank you again
your words really do resonate with a lot
of people and the power of your voice is
just
incredible thank you so much thank you
so much for that thank you brother
gina good morning gary how are you i'm
quite well how are you
i'm great i will try not to cry
10 years ago and my amazing boss said to
me do you know what garyvee is because
if you don't you need to
and you've really influenced the way
that i hustle
over the last 10 years so it is an honor
to talk to you today thank you for
taking the time
thank you so much um i'm a voice actor
and i hustled my ass off during the
pandemic last year
i landed some agents voiced my first
national commercial
and i've diversified the way i get my
business i have multiple agents across
the country
i'm on a ton of casting sites i do a ton
of direct marketing and i do social
media marketing
the thing about voice acting is it can
be very up and down i'll book a lot
and then nothing and in those slow
moments i made myself crazy saying you
know
what else could i be doing what more
could i be doing is it spend more money
is it join new sites is it
be 42 years old and create a tick tock
account i don't know so i'm wondering
um how do you get focused and formulate
a plan in slower moments
um you know first i in
for people that are living this kind of
life you have to be very thoughtful
about how you manage your money
right because i i notice a lot of people
that run hot and cold
don't spend money properly which then
when they have cold periods
creates an enormous amount of anxiety so
that's one thing that's on my mind for
you to think about that it's
hidden to a lot of people that live this
lifestyle which is
okay right some people have different
skill sets of managing money but it's a
very obvious one to me that causes
issue um two for me it's all about brand
building
i loved what i heard from you like i
would be you know when it's slow that's
a day when i can go in clubhouse for
five six seven hours and talk about
voice acting and host a room for nine
people
or reach out cold to other you know
voice actors or or whatever networking
is appropriate within my
ecosystem i i think the thing i think
about is brand building
and transacting and managing money
around it
the end it's a very simple game every
time you're you know it really can be
that simple gina like when
when you don't have anything brewing
you're building awareness starting a
podcast doing youtube show dming
unlimited podcasts to be on to speak
about voice acting
you know like just just grinding you
know working
because i can't be on a job then when
i'm doing a job i'm doing a job
but most of all i think the undertone to
this whole community
is money management because i just see
it time and time again
people overspending when they've got
dollars coming
in which makes them vulnerable when they
go through a three-month drought period
that makes a lot of sense i appreciate
that and um i just want to say you've
truly pushed me through some ups and
downs over the last decade i appreciate
it so much thank you
thank you so much for that gina really
have a great day
jerry hey gary
how are you i just want to say thank you
you've significantly changed the
trajectory of my life
and i really appreciate it um just for
all the content you put out
um i took over my parents restaurant and
we've you know
been able to significa over that
really a lot of it based off your
content thank you
thank you brother i am in iowa
and here we don't have any professional
sports teams so our big is
our big team is the um iowa hopkins
university here
and we're in college town and we have um
unique opportunities where
just you know they come and eat at a
restaurant a lot and then once they
graduate and it's you know legal for
them to
promote or you know kind of sponsor or
we sponsor them
and we have athletes that are willing to
do that and that's kind of like the
unique opportunity that we have
i'm just wondering is there any like do
you have any advice on how to partner
or what's the best way to utilize that
well do you know about the upcoming law
change
and rule change
so it's called it's yeah it's called
name image and likeness
and i uh like it looks like as of this
august if everything keeps going smooth
college athletes will be able to be
compensated so i think your whole
world's about to flip upside down
yeah so how would how would you start
planning
some athletes that just graduated they
were seniors and now a couple of them
will probably end up in the nfl
and we're in conversation with them i
just don't know
like but for a restaurant it's just
similar to like chipotle style
yeah i mean i mean it's there's no rules
right
you could say i'll give you food for
free for life if you give me five
instagram posts right like
and you know that they're gonna oh is it
just like where it's more like
commercially or is it like
just them coming to eat or just saying
that they eat there
no i think it's commercial i think it's
i think it's influencer marketing for a
restaurant i think they come in
they take a photo with your burrito or
your hamburger your coffee like
no i think it's classic you know
influencer marketing in my opinion
tagging tagging the restaurant things of
that nature but i think the bigger game
now
is that you're going to be able to
you know you know do this while they're
there
and as you can imagine you know sean
green when he was on campus
is better for you than when he's with
the jets and everybody who cares is in
new york and not getting their iowa
right
i think you create does iowa consider
their colors
gold and black or is it yellow and black
yeah i think you create a black and gold
card here's what i would do if i own
your place
you create a black and gold card right
with a barcode or i don't know how your
pos works
but you basically say to kids you know
um you know an instagram photo in your
feed that you can't delete
for every time you come in and use it
and get free food
right and that's it and then you just
monitor it i don't know if you can track
it so like again
if derek pagel came in and buys too much
food because he's hooking up all his
friends you cut it off you just
you have conversations human combo like
hey for yourself maybe a plus one
occasionally plus three because you know
a group of four friends but
don't be a pig we'll keep an eye on it
and away you go
make sense yeah i appreciate it thanks
you got it brother take care
zahar how are you hi gary
i'm wonderful how are you i'm extremely
well thank you
well thank you so much for hosting this
room i think we all really appreciate it
um so i'll try to be quick my question
is
um for myself personally i
have been in international development
for about 15 years
i've traveled the world on no money i
work in film and television now
and when
there are so many facets of my life
where i know i could kind of like add
value to other people
when you're talking about building a
personal brand
how do you like what strategy is best to
use because there's so many different
facets
would it be better to focus on building
different platforms for
each like section of my life
no no i think i think you put out your
whole life but to your point
if you love music and dancing doing that
on tick tock smarter than doing that
on linkedin right so every platform has
its
slang but i think about it as real life
you're you
and if you're going to a fancy dinner
with executives
you're going to dress a certain way
you're going to talk a certain way
you're going to act a certain way
if you're going with your girlfriends to
vegas for the weekend you're going to be
a different version of yourself if
you're
hanging out with your siblings or
parents or grandmother you're going to
be a different version
if you're you know at a at a festival
like so
always be you always be prepared to
share any part of you
but recognize the context of the room
that you're in
the platform that you're in what's the
slang what's the style what's the vibe
of that ecosystem
yeah that makes complete trouble with
because
sense
example like i come onto clubhouse and
we're having all of these like social
impact conversations where there's so
much value being added
and then when people transition over to
my instagram it's
way more about my travel which doesn't
really kind of
that's okay yeah that's okay though i
i know so which is better than i think
so comma
i think it's time that you put in some
of your social impact
on your instagram and be okay with
getting 47 likes instead of 293.
everyone's so [ __ ] in jail based on
trying to get the same amount or more
social
math transactions per post
that they've boxed themselves in i mean
there's literally people that are
dressing you know guys that take their
shirts off
because they know they're going to get
more likes even though they want to talk
about
sports i literally have guys saying
things like gary i wanna
i wanna put out sports cards content but
i did it once
it got 18 likes i deleted it right away
but if i put out my [ __ ]
shirtless photo i'm gonna get four
thousand i'm like well what do you like
what do you want like do you want to do
you want girls gawking at you like do
you need that or do you want to
move yourself into a career of like
buying and flipping sports cards because
if you do
you better start posting that way zara i
i
my entire audience in 2009 for three
years was built around wine
when i started making videos about
business nobody
not that's not true 15 liked it but the
85
were like what the [ __ ] is this like i
don't care about that talk about pinot
grigio
like you wanna like when people click on
your
you know on your instagram i mean it
really hurts you because like when i
click on your profile right now you
don't even have your socials connected
because you're insecure about that
vulnerability
well the thing is about 10 years ago i
was
i institutionalized funding for villages
in africa so i wanted a platform
and ran for miss universe canada and
then i started getting death threats
from the arab community so i like
literally became super private for a
very very long time i respect that
and then now i'm at the point where i
just don't give a [ __ ] and
i there's a lot of information
especially towards you know the arab
female population that
i would love to share because i feel
like i'm showing my liberation in that
sense
you should there's so much there i mean
i i invested in muslim girl
for that reason because there needs to
be far more conversation around this
it's a very
if for the people listening that don't
know it's extremely it's
it's extremely challenging in a world
where people can
hide and be cowards to be a woman to
begin with
to add being a muslim woman i mean it's
[ __ ]
it's very challenging luckily you're at
the part of your life now
where you recognize 99.9999999999999999
of that feedback is from people that are
hurt and they're just sharing their hurt
and trying to tear you down
and you're now ready to live your life
oh yeah 100 so go live so go live it i
gave you the answers
all right see you thank you you're
welcome take care
nicole hey gary
um thank you so much for inviting me up
here i am
a huge fan of yours and i really do
um attribute a lot of my success to a
lot of your practices especially
um jab jab right hook but i run a
boutique real estate brokerage in
houston
and also a few other complimentary
ancillary
companies i'm really struggling with
being mindful of my sanity while being
kind to myself with setting boundaries
as a mom of three kids how can i still
add maximum value
and continue to give while being careful
not to overextend myself
i feel like it's moms we have to be
perfect moms and perfect entrepreneurs
yeah i mean you're welcome so i think
this is an issue for
everybody and it pops up quite a bit in
the mom community
there is no perfect nicole right like
you know that
i think i think it's about how you
balance your judgment on yourself
let's make this a combo not just a
standard question like
when i say that nicole like you do
understand what i'm saying right like
you're the judge and the jury
i mean what every og parent will tell
you anyway is no matter how much you try
your parents are going to blame your
kids are going to blame you for
everything anyway
and i actually think that's a liberating
kind of comment
and i think like you know like like you
know i hear in the mom community a lot
like you don't get it we have to be a
perfect mom and a perfect
you know entrepreneur i'm like no i
don't think you is when i talk to my
friends i'm like i don't think you get
it
everybody has that there are dads that
feel like they have to provide the
finances if they have a stay-at-home mom
or
vice versa there are moms who are the
entrepreneur the mom and the bread
winner
there are people who are insecure about
their looks and
they they're like you don't get it when
you're 380 pounds the world like
there are minorities they're like white
males have plenty of their own michigan
too like you know everybody's got stuff
and i think it's
this judgment on ourselves that is the
ultimate game
like you're just i think you just have
to realize
if you have good intent and you're
trying as hard as you can
if you have a bad tuesday or a bad may
or a bad 2021 it's still gonna be okay
and once humans understand that then
[ __ ] gets good
wow thank you so much i mean i think
what you said is definitely
spot on um i am definitely
my own worst critic when it comes to
feeling like i have to do
everything all at one time a hundred
like even the way you asked the question
and even the way you read it like i just
could
taste it like you're the judge of you
once you start accepting yourself for
your efforts
and your intent instead of the output
that is judged by the outside you're
judging yourself because you're
overvaluing other people's opinions
nicole
i absolutely am thank you so much gary
nicole yeah i think this is going to
help people so i'm keeping you on like
you understand what i'm saying right oh
yeah 100 110 percent
definitely my own worst critic yeah and
the why
but why and you'll see if you play this
out it's very likely because you're
overvaluing other people's opinions
whether that's your mother
whether it's your sister whether that's
your best friend whether it's the
community
you need to get into a place where you
just don't value their opinion on your
motherhood and your entrepreneurship
yeah i definitely need to re-evaluate
people that i have around me
and put myself in a better place to
and nicole let's stay here because i
think you're helping a lot of people
right now
you know yes you can audit your circle
and start to focus on that
you could also change the narrative
which is when
sally magoo is making a snarky comment
for whatever reason you can really
genuinely be like
sally magu i really appreciate that and
i'm sure it's coming from a nice place
but you worry about parenting your kid
and i'll worry about parenting mine
yeah um was just in a situation with
that this week
uh and i i definitely i had to exit
myself from the situation
because um you know as a mom it's really
hard to get parental criticism
from somebody else who feels like
they're doing a better job than you
yeah and and don't forget parenting is
like a sports game
that mom may be thinking they're doing a
better job than you
but the score is 17 to 7 in the first
quarter of a basketball game
one thing that might help you nicole is
say
that's cute but like let's see how these
kids lives turn out
and oh by the way parents having their
self-esteem wrapped up
in what their kids doing is the ultimate
vulnerability
you can be proud and love your kid but
like too many parents are
deep in this [ __ ] now and whether the
kid is nice
dresses [ __ ] is good at sports is not
a good student all that [ __ ] has gotten
way too close the reason we've gotten
too deep in this [ __ ]
people people really had better
boundaries in the past
kids went outside parents didn't know
every [ __ ] little thing
i had 800 things brewing my mom knew
none of that
and i think that's another thing for you
to layer into this conversation nicole
if you think that sally magoo who's
judging you has any [ __ ] clue of
what's going on with their
child that makes me laugh
yeah uh yeah that hits home
i'm uh i my daughter is a competitive
cheerleader and that is a
really really tough field to be in it's
like the dance moms world if you've ever
seen that show
and that's definitely not my scene like
i stay in my lane i do my work and
uh yeah and it's it's definitely tough
because
not only are they in their kids business
but they're in everybody else right
it's it's it's it's unfortunate
and really once you flip your mind into
feeling compassion for them
instead of anger towards them your life
will get way better when i come across
that in my life
i smile with kindness and i'm like i
really appreciate your
interest but i've got this and i really
wish you and your family nothing but
good
and the conversation's over
that is incredibly powerful
practice being the bigger person and
shutting the door for any engagement
then you're kind and candorous
and you're moving on you're not giving
them any ammo for engagement
people's people's overreaction to that
behavior
is what feeds the oxygen of that
behavior when you say listen
karen i really appreciate it and i'm you
know i'm sure you're a wonderful person
and from your perspective i can see how
maybe you came to that conclusion but as
you can imagine just like i don't know
everything about your daughter
you don't know everything that's going
on and i promise you i feel very
comfortable in the way this is going
for the happiness of my child in a
hundred year period not a hundred day
period
so i appreciate it if you ever want to
talk about things that's cool like that
kind of talk got it
yeah 100 thanks gary you got it
all right jesse what's good
hey what's up gary thank you for the
opportunity to ask you a question and
open up this room
and thanks zane for bringing me up um so
my
question is you talk about basically you
talk
i think it's a remarkable platform and
i'm devastated that i'm so so busy
actually like one funny thing about me
jesse is
i'm such a prolific content producer but
it's because i built a strategy
seven years ago and built out a team
that allowed me to do it
brother i am literally in meetings 12
hours a day
so i don't have the time or capacity
to do what i did in 2007 to 11 which was
live on twitter which let me do it but
i'm telling you right now
i would spend every minute i could on
clubhouse right now building community
okay do you see like the way the way you
talked about
linkedin yes i've seen i see it exactly
that way for the people that have
something to say and are good at
communicating by voice
correct this is not a distribution
platform this is a platform to actually
engage
and right this exact second i'm
challenged for time
however i literally scheduled for
8 30 to 9 30s this week to be on
clubhouse because i'm that passionate
about building up and as a matter of
fact for everybody who's listening right
now tonight actually
this is a good promo and benji i'll try
to get to you it's so fun to have you in
here but i do have a 10 15 with a client
but tonight
from 8 15 to 9 15 i have a huge
talk with all my vayner sports athletes
in a room
so i'm really trying to hack jessie
because i really believe in it but to
your point
the the reason you haven't seen me on
here as much
i mean i was aware of it in march swann
who's in the chat here
got me you know locked you know again
march i was just trying to make sure my
company was afloat but i saw the silicon
valley crew
that i've seen so many times jump on and
i was like [ __ ] i gotta get there it's
happening
my friend swan who's down here finally
like was like yo you got to get your
[ __ ] together got me
the invite i jumped in in july i did a
couple things i enjoyed it but i was
just too deep
in fixing my company because we were
going through cobid
and i was i had a lot of
responsibilities and family stuff i just
couldn't get there
but i really stepped up a little bit
here
by comparison in 2021 and i'm trying to
carve out more and more and more time
but to your point what we're seeing is
me not being able to live my thesis
because the land grab of attention here
is extraordinary
i'm all about it i'm about that life i'm
just i just have to put in the reps
and me finding the time right now is
extremely challenging
but you should be living here as much as
you possibly can and so should all 2000
people that are in this room
appreciate that thank you of course i
hope you have the best day
benjamin get you in real quick
you got it brother hey thank you so much
for what you're doing for the community
when i was on your podcast you asked me
a unique question about percentages how
important title thumbnail and content is
i'm gonna do the
same for you what is the percentage of
time you should be spending on these
different platforms from youtube
instagram
facebook to linkedin and now clubhouse
go percentage voice so benji great
question let me ask you a question
of the platforms you're on which one
gets the most
organic reach because you've already
because i know you have a profile
and i know youtube's one of them has
the most organic reach currently based
on the algorithm and the community that
you built
well definitely youtube the second is
now clubhouse
makes sense so to me benji if i'm you i
would probably
create a lot more youtube videos notice
how earlier i said to somebody
hey start making instagrams that don't
do as well but
accomplish what you want if i'm benji
i'm putting out way more youtube videos
around
clubhouse around linkedin and around
tick tock
because those are the three places where
organic reaches through the roof
and so that you can diversify and build
up profiles
on all three make sense
totally thank you so much it's great to
talk to you thank you
love you pal all right everybody thank
you so much for this i'll be back
tonight
but it's very narrow it's a sports
conversation 8 15 to 9 15
eastern uh vaynersports is doing a
pretty cool like jam session for people
to listen into
zayn may nicole zane
may and tan excuse me thank you so much
for uh moderating thanks for being part
of my team
and i just want to thank you know all of
you that were in here
throughout this conversation i hope you
have a wonderful wonderful wonderful
day thank you for the 2000 plus that
joined us thank you dustin who's
recorded this
hopefully we can get some clips out of
it swan i see you in there thank you
matt always good to see you brother love
seeing your face hillman
uh hope everybody has a great great day
please hit me up on twitter garyvee
right now i'm going into a meeting
and i want to feel the feedback from
this session so hit me up with
at garyvee use the hashtag clubhouse to
give me your feedback on how this
session was and i hope you get into the
next one i think i'm doing it tomorrow
let me triple check uh yes tomorrow 8 30
to 9 30.
i hope to see you see ya youtube watcher
what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon